hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde ihr habt euch zahlreich
gewünscht dass ich mal wieder auf -
reagiere die ihr über mich gemacht habt
von daher darf ich euch heute recht
herzlich willkommen heißen zu einer
weiteren episode in der ich genau das
machen werde
ist ja auch irgendwie logisch wenn es
schon im titel steht wenn ich vor dem
spiegel stehe und merke wie hässlich ich
eigentlich bin kann gar nicht sein weil
er am murger hat aus
willst du dir den tag versauen musst du
in den spiegel
schauen was ist das für ein foto davon
ja ich bin die person die beiträge
speichert aber diese nie wieder anschaut
bin wirklich ich hab sogar 30 orten oder
so auf instagram laser luca und wir
sagten sprecher bei mir nie wieder
angucke mathe ist wenn du nicht
verstehst was du nicht verstehst
das ist einfach wahr
es ist so häufig so gewesen folgender
machte klar so dass lehrerin meinte und
hat gegner nachfrage und ich wusste
nicht mal was ich fragen soll
scheiße war ich kacke dieser moment wenn
man sich in den bus setzt sein handy
rausholen aus gewohnheit anfängt zu
packen
elf minuten geht mir jemand auf den sack
ich ohrfeige jetzt mein gott was war das
für eine frisur luca
ich habe ich schon alles durch kann
irgend jemand von euch mal bitte auf
instagram foto hochladen mit einer
compilation von allen meinen frisuren
bisher ja meine bildschirmzeit unter der
woche versus meine bildschirmzeit am
wochenende das ist
wahr
irgendwie sind alle eure - einfach war
ich wenn der lehrer wieder jemanden
aufrufen will
ich würde so stark wie talk wenn ihr
euch so einfach so wenn du etwas auf
morgen verschiebt und morgen dann da ist
[Musik]
gut hintergrundstory zu dem foto wir
sind dann nach hamburg gefahren und ich
meinte ich kann easy hinten sitzen wir
wittern nicht schlecht wer musste nach
zehn minuten auf platz zu gehen
luca ich trinke nicola oder sowas auch
ja ja was hatte ich da an ich war ja
bloß ihn blass als mensch der moment
wenn du gerade aus der dusche kommt und
direkt an fängst du schon
das ist so schlimm entweder im sommer
dann kommst du nicht verschwitzt die
dusche gegner da draußen wieder 35 grad
- ok warum hab ich grad gebucht oder
vielleicht kennst oder andere von euch
wenn man irgendwie sport gemacht hat man
geht direkt danach im gym oder beim
weisen namen fußballer umkleiden duschen
und danach schwitzt man noch nach
deswegen meine theorie nach dem sport
immer den stunde bis 30 minuten warten
mit dem duschen albert einstein dessen
nichts gegen mich und meine freunde mich
fragen ob ich zeit habe ich nehme muss
das neue video von luca sehen
vielleicht sollte sie erst mal deutsch
lernen wie ich mich fühle wenn ich mal
kochen
[Musik]
alles eins zu eins tun ich doppelpunkt
kann ich das ladekabel haben die andere
person sagt darauf hin wie viel prozent
hast du ich
immer so junge scheiß drauf wie viel
prozent ich habe das von dem ladekabel
familie also wir müssen jetzt salz mit
wasser setzt dazu bitte eure
schutzbrillen auf safety first
ich glaube ich bin die sache nur witzig
war dass ich dumm screenshots von mir
sind jetzt bereit falls das video
überhaupt nicht lustig und ich tue etwas
komisches weil ich allein zu hause bin
auch ich was ist wenn ihr überall
versteckte kameras sind wir nie gedacht
wenn du einfach nur einen witz machen
wollte es aber dann eltern die plötzlich
eine predigt halten ich schwöre immer so
bin ich der einzige der das als kind
dachte 1909
[Musik]
ich höre es ist
für mich sind die dann auch alle so
rumgelaufen wie in diesen alten filme
mal so viel zu gerade haltung dann immer
so ein bisschen auch zum schnell
herumgelaufen und komplett schwarz weiß
ich habe zwei probleme im leben
schwierigkeiten beim einschlafen und
schwierigkeiten beim aufwachen das ist
auch leider wieder komplett war was war
das eigentlich da wieder für eine friese
junge was hab ich denn hey ich mit
meinen geschwistern früher im auto schau
der mond folgt uns
dick und doof tik tok account hier hand
in hand am baden mit luca und sandra
dick und doof instagram
ja seitdem in dem video podcast haben
können wir dinge direkt zeigen im
podcast plus auf ticker kann mir halt
die ganze zeit bewegtbild was wir
täglich hochladen also folgt uns gern da
die talk als mutig und beruf und ich
heiße laser luca wenn auch aktiv wenn du
dir deine bewerbung vor dem absenden
noch mal durchliest und dir denkst was
ein toller mensch so wäre ich auch
[Musik]
schreibt ihm ein scheiß verein
mich super mit excel aus excel oder
nutze ich mein sohn 1 zusammenzählen
stark auch wieder was das für eine
friese hier war 6 in 1 duschgel auf der
hinterseite linker arm rechter arm
rechtes bein linkes beiden rumpf und
kopf habe ich auch der einzige der die
ganze zeit solche 601 sachen benutzt
vor praktisch alltag sich arme bauch
haare luca sagt nein zu schönen filtern
aber ja
nehmen wir auf instagram folgt wisst ihr
dass ich diesen filter über alles liebe
wie ich doppelpunkt rede mit meinem
crash meine freunde im hinterkopf
[Musik]
wenn deine mutter dich ruft und dann
einfach nicht mehr antwortet
ja es einfach war ich auf der suche nach
meinem haus in mainz
oder wer hat euch ins hirn geschissen
dass wir so einen humor habt ich nachdem
ich schon die erste aufgabe in der
arbeit nicht verstehen
er hat auch wieder war dann schmückt man
so zweiten aufgabe denkt sich dann so
auch die checks ich auch nicht und dann
ist aus dem fenster gucken bisschen über
das leben nachdenken ich am überlegen
mit was ich meine zeit verschwenden soll
das ist wahr
es hat twitter facebook einen menschen
mit twitter und facebook casino
[Musik]
sagt jetzt nicht wegen meiner nase
arschlöcher meine mutter du wächst da
noch rein
auch immer so gewesen wenn ich mal
wieder zu spät betont überlege welche
ausreden
gibt viel zu viel mühe bei die werke
niemand doppelpunkt wie ich mich nach
zehn liegestützen fühle
ja ich mache hat auch sportler
wenn man die kontrolle über sein leben
im alter programm tier diese kacke raus
denn meine beste freundin und ich
alleine sind nun endlich über jeden
lästern können man lässt hat nicht
freunde habe ich auch noch nie gemacht
ich wenn ich es endlich geschafft habe
männlich aus
es einfach wieder luca mobbing hier
niemand doppelpunkt kinder vor dem
aquarium oh mein gott hier sind nemo und
[Musik]
ich sagte auch
letztens blende ich euch jetzt auch
einfach so ein
[Musik]
letztendlich das heutige video ist dann
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn euch luca reagiert mal
wieder auf flughafens gefallen hat der
lask einen daumen hoch unter dem video
hier da abonniert main kanal und klickt
auf die glocke wenn ihr weitere videos
nicht verpassen wollt alle links zu
unserem podcast zu instagram zu tik tok
seinem 2 kanal wo ich aktuell auch aktiv
infineon in der video beschreiben heute
schaut mal vorbei und
wir finden uns im auto ihr könnt meinen
kanal abonnieren und oder
doch in den anderen teil angucken von
luke am 1
zu blinzeln